One of the most important rules in
security is the rule of least privilege.
Put simply, this means a user or
an application only has enough
permission to do its job, nothing extra.
You've already experienced this
within your virtual machine,
although you may not be aware of it yet.
When we access our virtual machine,
using vagrant ssh.
We're logged in as a standard
user named, vagrant.
Let's try running a command only
an administrative user would be
allowed to run.
Let's list all of the files with
in the ubuntu users ssh directory.
You see, we get this error here,
permission denied.
Only the ubuntu user or
the root user can read the files
within this directory.
You may be thinking, but I am the
administrator of this virtual machine.
I am root.
So how do I actually log in as root?
It's time to learn about super user.